[Musique]
c'est l'un des endroits les plus
sauvages de la méditerranée
jean marc est un de ses gardiens
voilà on arrive ici sur la ligne de
crête qui nous sépare d'un côté de
marseille en pente douce et ici des
calanques avec un paysage beaucoup plus
déchiqueté je dirais beaucoup plus
abrupte il est la mémoire des calanques
les plantes les arbres les sentiers il
en connaît tous les recoins son amour
pour ce paysage lui a fait quitter le
monde de la finance
aujourd'hui il conte l'histoire de ceux
liés aux touristes de passage
les calanques ont été formés il ya 5
millions d'années ça a été creusé ce ne
sont pas des vallées glaciaires comment
quelqu'un quelquefois on l'a prétendu
toutes les grandes des aventures de
l'histoire de marseille tous les grands
événements se retrouvent dans les
calanques
on sait qu'on a vu les phocéens arrivé
ici il ya 2600 ans à portée de main on à
la grotte cosquer la grotte
préhistorique dont les gravures évolué
entre 10 - 10 mille moines trente mille
ans on se retourne et on voit l'île de
riou ou saint-exupéry a disparu pour
remonter le temps quatre heures de
marche sont nécessaires sur des sentiers
qui donne accès à des criques aux eaux
cristallines
[Musique]
les calanques de sormiou et ses cabanons
la crique vierge dans vos immobile et
majestueuse ces roches blanches se
découvre en escalade à pied ou par
bateau les calanques qui s'étendent sur
20km de martigues à la ciotat reçoivent
tous les jours la visite de navettes
touristiques
plus de deux millions de visiteurs
chaque année à la découverte d'une
dizaine de criques du parc national
ces visiteurs garderont le souvenir d'un
cadre exceptionnel
pourtant cette eau limpide dissimule
depuis plus d'un siècle les assauts
réguliers de la pollution humaine
station d'épuration saturés des déchets
industriels qui empoisonnent les fonds
sous-marins et contaminent le littoral
enquête dans l'un des plus beaux
endroits de la méditerranée mais
peut-être l'un des plus polluées les
calanques ont gagné il y a quatre ans
l'appellation de parc national pour
protéger ce site naturel
une trentaine de personnes parmi elles
david il travaille à l'office national
des forêts depuis 20 ans bonjour c'est
l'office national forest tenait une
petite carte sur les sentiers et une
information sur la faune et la flore que
vous allez voir
voilà bonne journée ils balisent les
sentiers pour éviter que les touristes
ne se perde
mais surtout ils veillent à préserver
cet environnement à l'état sauvage le
massif des calanques fait que on a des
concentrations du public sur des petits
sites naturels donc forcément qui dit
beaucoup de monde sur un petit 6 10 de
la dégradation involontaire mais
mécanique sans combat éviter les départs
de feu
un mégot mal éteint et les 8500 hectares
de collines et de garrigue pourrait
disparaître en fumée
bonjour l'office national des forêts
vous pouvez juste quand votre briquet
aujourd'hui ça sera un avertissement ce
touriste et risque une amende de 135
euros
comprenez bien pourquoi on interdit de
fumer tout sauf de flammes aux sites
interdits très chaud évidemment mais je
suis aussi d'accord merci bonne journée
[Musique]
les gardiens des calanques sont présents
sur terre mais aussi sur mer tu la mets
sur l'a11 objets longs mois à la mère
sur ce zodiac stéphanie et julien font
la chasse aux déchets
aux plaisanciers trop pressé jugement
et à tous ceux qui s'aventurent trop
près du littoral
soit pas nettement pas lions affamés
laama donc il est possible
derrière ces bouées jaunes la zone est
interdite au mouillage pour protéger la
flore sous-marine régulièrement arraché
par les ancres de bateaux
bonjour
royer pour le parc national des
calanques c'est un petit peu
d'informations simplement pour vous dire
que mattia des bouées jaunes petit peu
de vent qui ferme sa tombe et il a
interdit d'y pénétrer de jeter l'ancré
[Musique]
pas rapidement les régates qui va venir
se mettre au même endroit et du coup
après tous les bateaux à venir se mettre
là où ce sera possible
parmi toutes les criques des calanques
il en existe une
où les plaisanciers s'aventure rarement
une crique bien connue des marseillais
henri ogier et isabelle poitou ont bien
voulu nous l'a montré
ils sont scientifiques et milite pour la
préservation des calanques à dix minutes
du port de marseille lens de cortiou des
tunnels ont été creusés dans la roche
celui de droite les égouts de marseille
les autres rejoignent la station
d'épuration de la ville phocéenne et le
fleuve l'huveaune plus nous approchons
plus l'odeur est nauséabonde dont vous
pouvez voir look est vraiment troubles
regarder toutes les particules dans
l'eau
regardez la mousse ce sont les
détergents qui passent toutes les
filières de dépollution saisir que ce
sont des pollutions qui ne sont pas
biodégradables et pas qu'à cinq ans
elles sont indestructibles et elles vont
s'accumuler à mesure que les eaux vont
arriver c'est tout plein de sédiments
fins pas de sédiments où là on sent que
c'est de la matière aux suspensions voit
presque même de la file à m'emmerder
enfin bref d'après ces scientifiques ces
eaux polluées perturberait toute forme
de vie sous marine
cette fric te ment scandaleux qu'il y
ait un tel rejet dans un parc national
c'est le seul parc national au monde qui
est discrédité par un permis de polluer
et de tuer
que contiennent ces eaux empoisonne tels
les calanques
nous décidons d'effectuer des
prélèvements à la source pour accéder au
tunnel
il n'existe pas de sentiers
[Musique]
nous réalisons un premier prélèvement
des eaux qui s'écoulent de la station
d'épuration et du fleuve l'huveaune
puis un deuxième à la sortie des égouts
de marseille où l'eau est censé elle
aussi être traité
les échantillons sont confiés à un
laboratoire indépendant et les résultats
sont sans appel les prélèvements
contiennent plus de 45 contaminant des
perturbateurs endocriniens des toxiques
cancérigènes et des hydrocarbures en
quantité quatre à huit fois plus élevé
que la norme européenne
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que les eaux sales de la
cité phocéenne qui se retrouveraient
dans les calanques
à quelques kilomètres plus à l'est
cassis en plein coeur du parc national
ses plages et ses sports nautiques très
prisée des touristes
[Musique]
il y a quelques semaines cet appelée
east michel dron a fait une découverte
une canalisation qui embarrasserait les
pouvoirs publics
là c'est pareil il faut pas de
claustrophobie comme il n'aime pas trop
contraindre au tour aux alentours de ces
canalisations
on vient là on se change tranquille on
fait une mission commando là bas on
arrive on jette tout je laisse le bateau
en remorque et je pars vite dans la
plaie comme ça je suis pas très content
l'opération a lieu à 100 mètres à peine
de la plage et de ces baigneurs
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
muni d'une caméra l'apnéiste plonge à
cinq mètres de profondeur voici l'une
des canalisations d'une station
d'épuration un nuage d'excréments
s'échappe du tuyau
pendant la saison touristique
la station déborde elles seraient
saturés
ces eaux sales sont directement rejetée
en mer
ça pue c'est immonde beaubien j'ai ce
goût dans la bouche si on était bien
dans un tourbillon de détritus
d'excréments ccfc c'est infect voilà et
en même temps m du bord voilà vous avez
des plages qui sont là les plages qui
sont derrière donc suivant les courants
aujourd'hui ben ça se jette sur les
rochers quand il vendait sa part tout
là-bas par bon bah voilà une catastrophe
des touristes navigue juste au dessus de
la canalisation aurait trouvé clerc
l'enfant
les films sont centrés en retenir le
caca et là bas les flics je croyais en a
pas c'est pour ça que ça sort noir et
marron c'est vraiment offrir a annoncé
garder là où il ya les tourbillons
selon la mairie de quessy serge et
noirâtre ont été traités et dépollués
pourtant les trois jours qui ont suivi
cette plongée michel est tombé malade il
a contracté une gastro entérite
dans ce site protégé au large de cassis
il existerait une autre pollution plus
diffuse et moins visibles les premiers
en avoir pris conscience
ce sont les pêcheurs
gérard a vu les zones de pêche se
réduire puis disparaître
revenez pêcher ici parce que ici c'était
le coup mon le canyon il y avait des
merlus il y avait des congrès y avait de
la lentille abeilles avaient tous comme
rouler aujourd'hui la plupart des
poissons sont partis et ceux qui restent
porte les stigmates de la contamination
soyez une res world
[Musique]
ben oui
toi et la ligne il est resté deux heures
à lola car regardez moi bien sûr monde
douala voila voila le résultat
et ça si on l'analyse c'est pas de la
terre que j'ai ramassé dans les
carrières de la sûreté à st cette zone
là on a choisi de la remplir de déchets
industriels
voilà cette zone là elle et elle et elle
est quasi morte elle est quasi morte et
ça fait 27 30 ans qu'il n'ya plus un
pêcheur je vous fait faire le tour que
vous voulez vous n'allez pas trouver un
seul un gène de perge en cause une usine
qui déverse ses déchets industriels dans
l'eau des calanques à 330 mètres de
profondeur
plus de 30 tonnes d'une boue rouge ont
été déversées en mer ces 50 dernières
années pour savoir d'où elles viennent
c'est un vrai jeu de piste il faut
suivre ces canalisations qui les rejette
sous la mer puis sur terre
à travers les champs et les villages sur
40 km
tout au bout gardanne surnommée la ville
rouge
une fine poussière asphyxie la ville
cette terre rouge vient d'afrique en
guinée c'est de la bauxite alumine elle
sert à la fabrication de composants
électroniques de nos téléphones
portables nos ordinateurs ou encore
notre électroménager
cette terre est traité dans cette usine
qui emploie plus de 400 salariés
après transformation
les déchets sont rejetés en mer ont-ils
un impact sur le milieu marin
olivier dubuquoy et géographe et
militant écologiste
son combat prouver que l' usine à
masquer pendant des années les dégâts
qu'elle a provoqués sur l'environnement
il a épluché les 200 rapports produits
par la société en 25 ans en 93
l'industriel toujours publier un petit
petit dossier qui s'appelle résidus
inerte usine de gardanne et dans leur
constat personnel
ils disent les poissons prélevés par
chalutage dans le canyon son sens
tactique
selon ce géographe les résultats sont
contestables alteo minimiserait les
conséquences de ces rejets en mer des
informations sur ce dossier elle est
assez impressionnante
je donne un exemple concret il ya
différentes façons par exemple de faire
du prélèvement dans le sédiment en
termes de prélèvement soit on peut
choisir de prélever dans laxe du canyon
et c'est ce qui est le plus pertinent en
outre élevées en bordure du canyon dans
l'occurrence sa toxicité sera bien moins
puisque le sédiment sera moins impactés
donc on fera parler
cette étude en 10 ans pourront ces
toxiques mais c'est pas très toxique
dans ses comptes rendu les conclusions
dalle théo sont récurrentes
les boues rouges aurait peu d'effet sur
le milieu marin
il y un an devant la grogne des
habitants et des écologistes
la ministre de l'environnement demande
une contre-expertise allende cesse un
laboratoire d'état indépendant
plus de mille poissons d'espèces
différentes sont analysés
et les résultats contredisent les
rapports d'alto et bien on observe des
contaminations
statistiquement significative en termes
de niveau de concentration dans la zone
de roger et donc ces poissons sont plus
contaminés on voit la trace du rejet de
la société alteo d'après l'ong cesse le
taux d'arsenic de mercure et de plomb
contenu dans les poissons est de dix à
mille fois plus élevé que dans l'étude
dalle théo
depuis le 1er janvier 2016 lusine
affirme ne plus rejeter deux bouts en
mer
grâce à un nouveau système de filtration
ce nouveau procédé le patron d'al théo
eric duchesne souhaite nous le montrer
alors ici on est devant l'installation
de traitement des eaux
donc c'est la dernière étape de notre
procédé avant de rejet à la mer
eric duchesne veut nous faire une
démonstration
il demande un de ses employés de
récupérer l'eau dans la cuve où elle est
filtrée avant d'être rejetés dans les
calanques
les déchets sont désormais incolore
aujourd'hui appris que cette lumière
plus de boue rouge projeté les boues
rouges sont vraiment fixé à la fois par
des filtres presses et de manière en
finition par l'installation de
filtration d'une suppression qui seront
ici
voir il pas
[Musique]
c'est un échantillon qui est un basique
mr génériques
n'est pas potable
dans cette eau il reste de la soude qui
est dissout qu'on n'a pas pu récupérer
dans nos procédés donc il ya peu près 2
g par litre de soude
nous l'interrogeons sur l'étude de
landes c'est ce qui révèle que l' usine
à intoxiquer les fonds marins qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette dernière et
cette cassette de lanxess oui alors il
ya des chiffres qui vont dans un sens à
des chiffres qui vont dans l'autre sens
un lent face n'a pas forcément parler
des ours ans qui sont moins contaminées
dans la zone de rejet comparée à la zone
de référence
donc tout ça c'est enfin c'est assez
compliqué et
pour l'instant je peux pas en dire
beaucoup plus juste juste surfer sur la
pêche
on parle on parle de pollution mais je
voudrais juste quand même rappeler que
la plus sûre de la méditerranée cet
impôt
en 50 ans lusine de gardanne aurait
rejeté dans les calanques 2 millions 200
mille tonnes d'aluminium
plus de 9 millions de tonnes de fer 1700
tonnes de plomb et 20 mille six cents
kilos d'arsenic
une zone qui serait aujourd'hui
impossible à dépolluer
selon gérard le pêcheur la nouvelle
technique de filtration dalle théo ne
serait que de la poudre aux yeux
mon petit fils il va reprendre le bateau
j'ai pas mis de lui laisser un héritage
de voilà moi je veux que lui ça ils
sachent plus que c'est il faut il faut
stopper ça où trouver le moyen d'envoyer
de l'eau qu'ils soient consommables ici
de même si demain les jeunes de notre
dame arrive à épurer leurs flottes et
qui la boivent ou qu'ils arrosent de
leur potager
moi je leur signe un avis favorable
l'état vient d'autoriser lusine à se
débarrasser de ses déchets dans la mer
pendant encore six ans
aujourd'hui les boues rouges ne sont
plus déverser en mer mais stockées sur
des terrains à proximité de la ville de
gardanne à la merci des vents et des
pluies
[Musique]
dès que le thermomètre passe la barre
des 20 degrés les touristes affluent
dans la petite crique de samena sur la
commune de marseille
lieu ouais ça faisait vraiment top
réserver
on a l'impression nord c'est quoi
tu rentres îles isolées
là tout le monde est
une magnifique
les visiteurs l'ignorent mais les
rochers de cette crique sont infestés
par le pont
sur ces photos prises il ya cinq ans des
panneaux interdisait la baignade est
signalé la présence de plomb et
d'arsenic
mais depuis des mois les panneaux ont
disparu
la pollution remonte à plus d'un siècle
elle provient des usines chimiques
implantées le long du littoral
voici la plage de samena en 1851
elle servait de débarcadère à une
entreprise qui fabriquait du pont
le plomb étaient entreposés là où
aujourd'hui les touristes posent leurs
serviettes des usines
il y en avait plus d'une vingtaine dans
les calanques rolland qui habite juste à
côté
il se bat pour une dépollution du
littoral
alors là on arrive à un point de vue sur
l' usine de l'escalette qui a été la
première fonderie de plomb installé à
marseille et importance à vue à droite
là en direction de la ville à quelques
encablures 304 m vous avez l'usiné
legré-mante activités de fonderie de
plomb et s'est poursuivie par une usine
d'acide sulfurique et une usine d'acide
tartrique cette société a fermé en 2009
depuis faute de repreneur tout est
laissé à l'abandon
l'industriel avait construit une
cheminée rampante de 300 mètres de
hauteur à l'intérieur la pollution est
resté
une pollution indélébile disséminés
partout dans la nature des petits
cailloux noire des scories de plomb
pour connaître le taux de toxicité des
sols nous prélevons plusieurs
échantillons à différents endroits de la
zone
[Musique]
ils sont ensuite examinés dans ce
laboratoire du cnrs spécialisé dans les
analyses de sol grâce à un procédé laser
cette machine détermine la concentration
du taux de métaux lourds
en quelques secondes les résultats
tombent juste ici donc on voit
clairement ce pic l'a donc correspondre
au plan voilà là on aurait l'art
scénique des métaux lourds
normalement on ne trouve pas ceux des
pierres ordinaire vous allez dans votre
jardin vous prendrez une pierre si on
vous l'analyse ici on verra pas des pics
de plans et de l'art scénique
même si elle est toute petite quantité
ils sont tellement faibles qu'on peut
pas les détecter nos échantillons de
terre contiennent six mille fois plus de
plomb est mille fois plus d'arsenic que
la normale aucune évaluation sur la
santé publique de ceux qui vivent aux
abords de l'usiné n'a été menée jacques
habite juste à côté depuis plus de 40
ans passionné de jardinage
il n'a jamais cessé de plantes et fruits
et légumes parfois pendant des années on
a eu deux on a senti de très mauvaises
odeurs de
duff bruit de trucs comme ça qu'ils ont
été sûrement traiter un certain moment
et ont disparu et personne ne nous
alerter de la pollution qui avait dans
l'essonne à côté non la question s'est
pas posé personne n'en a parlé
mais il faut savoir que lorsqu'on fait
référence à une quarantaine d'années
derrière toutes ces questions qu'on se
pose ce jour ne se posait pas
depuis un an à l'hôpital nord de
marseille
plusieurs chercheurs ont décidé de mener
une étude sur les conséquences de ces
polluants sur les femmes enceintes et
les foetus
annie lévis en fait partie elle est
généticienne on sait aujourd'hui que la
femme enceinte est totalement vulnérable
parce que le placenta au lieu de faire
une barrière et d'empêcher un de que ces
éléments toxiques soient arrêtés au
contraire c'est une vraie éponge et
compte tenu de la petitesse du foetus ce
sont des doses qui vont de fait
entraîner des malformations et puis on
sait aujourd'hui que ça peut venir sans
être mal formatif entraîné des retards
de croissance intra utérin
c'est à dire un bébé qui va naître avec
un petit pois ou une grossesse qui va
s'arrêter plus tôt que prévu ou
quelquefois aussi entraîné des fausses
couches et des morts in utero dépolluer
lusine coûterait 15 millions d'euros ni
la ville ni l'état ni le propriétaire
n'en aurait les moyens
mais pourquoi aucun panneau ne prévient
les vacanciers des risques qu'ils
prennent sur les plages contaminés c'est
la question que nous avons posée à
didier réault président du parc national
des calanques les baignade ne sont pas
autorisées sont interdites libre à
chacun d'aller se baigner mais elles
sont interdites
il n'y a pas de surveillance de baignade
volontairement alors qu'il ya des
demandes de la part de la population
on est dans cette dans cette logique où
la mer est accessible à tout le monde et
chacun peut prendre la liberté est
pollué là bas le sol est pollué après la
mer elle est là elle ravine évidemment
elle elle ramène des
les résidus des sédiments qui sont
évidemment pas
en conformité avec avec la santé
publique on est bien d'accord
[Musique]
face à l'inaction des pouvoirs publics
des actions citoyennes sont organisées
une goutte d'eau également
légaux oui d'ailleurs cette
je fus qu'est ce qu'on va faire le
garçon monte à un point b oui vous
éviter de marcher sur les plantes
on est dans un parc naturel ya des
espèces sauvages ya peut-être des études
scientifiques aussi avec des petites
étiquettes bon nettoyage et on à l'apéro
ici à 12h30 une fois par an ils sont
environ 1500 sur les plages et dans la
garrigue à ramasser du plus petit
déchets aux plus gros j'ai gagné j'ai
trouvé ça on m'a dit que ça c'était mon
compte double
une journée pour ramasser 100 mètres
cubes de déchets mais combien de temps
encore pour gommer la pollution humaine
et industrielle qui contamine les
calanques
des années sûrement seront nécessaires
pour que ce lieu mérite un jour son
label de parc national